Oh boy,
that's a really tough question is it's
kind of like asking a what are the,
what are the five countries you should
know about if you're not interested in
geology or geography or politics?
Um,
and the answer varies depending on what
your actual interests are or what are
the five companies you should know.
Uh,
but,
um,
and,
and the answer changes over time too.
Um,
uh,
back when I was getting started,
Lo these many decades ago,
uh,
the answers would have been Fortran,
cobol,
basic
lists and maybe Apl,
uh,
and uh,
those were very formative languages back
then and people learned a lot from
those.
But these days,
uh,
it might be more important for you to
know a Java script,
even if I'm a,
the only reason you know that is,
is that you know,
whether or not to click the enabled Java
script button in your browser,
um,
but javascript is a nice lightweight
object oriented language.
Um,
and,
uh,
that's why it can fit in a browser,
and,
uh,
do these things such as,
run little programs that,
uh,
that,
help you input your data.
And then send it off to a web server
somewhere.
Um,
there are,
there are heavier weight,
a object oriented languages.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
the elephant in the room is sort of
Java.
You can't really make a list of modern
languages without talking about it.
Java is sort of the,
uh,
the Cobol of the 21st century.
I think it's a kind of heavyweight,
a verbose.
And uh,
everyone loves to hate it.
I'm not,
everyone will admit that,
but managers kind of like it because,
um,
it looks like you're getting a lot done.
Um,
you know,
if 100 lines of Java code,
uh,
accomplish a task,
then it looks like you've written a
hundred lines,
even though in a different language,
it might only take five lines,
you know,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
you can eat a one pound steak or you can
get a,
you know,
100 pounds of shoe leather and you feel
a greater sense of accomplishment after
the shoe leather.
But,
you know,
maybe there's some downsides.
Um,
but it also,
um,
because it is sort of considered an
industrial language and programmers,
they're sort of interchangeable parts,
a managers like it for that reason,
and for that reason,
a lot of Java jobs that have been
outsourced from the United States.
Um,
oh,
what other languages?
Um,
I think,
uh,
going in a different direction,
coming more from academia,
we have a language like a Haskell,
which we call a functional programming
language that means function in a
mathematical sense,
not in the sense of the other language
or other languages are dysfunctional.
Uh,
but a function mathematically has an
input and an output and it maps to,
um,
uh,
you know,
with a great deal of a mathematical
certainty what those,
what those are.
So,
um,
uh,
a
Haskell is one of those languages that a
mathematician type minded people love.
It's,
it's sort of a language for geniuses by
Jesus.
Um,
so you should probably know about it if
only to be able to say,
well,
is this Kinda like Haskell?
And if so,
then you know,
you have to hire some really smart
people to,
uh,
to program manage A.
Haskell is sort of a modern kind of
lists in that sense.
Um,
what else?
Uh,
well,
we can't,
we can't leave off modern languages
without talking about c,
the c language that's just spelled with
the letter c,
m is actually about 40 years old.
But,
um,
people have tried to replace,
see with other languages that are,
are like it,
and have by and large,
not succeeded because a c is a very
minimalistic language and very close to
the metal as we say on a,
on a machine and lets you get down and
do very fine grain stuff very
efficiently.
But it's a lot of hard work.
But once you've done that work,
you can run it pretty much everywhere.
So almost all the other languages that
you see,
a Java,
Perl,
whatever,
uh,
actually if you look down underneath,
they're actually implemented and see or,
or in a closely related language.
So,
um,
uh,
that,
that continues to be a very fundamental
language if only because everyone is
trying to reinvent it and not succeeding
in doing so.
And finally,
um,
for a fifth language a,
well,
you'd probably want to pick one of the
scripting languages.
Um,
there's,
there's several to choose from a,
there's python,
there's Ruby,
but of course I am prejudiced in favor
of Pearl,
uh,
because I think it has the,
um,
the liveliest community.
Um,
and because,
uh,
we,
have intentionally been redesigning it
lightly to leap frog,
uh,
all the,
other languages,
uh,
for the,
for the last number of years we've been
redesigning it to take out all the warts
that we've noticed over time.
And we figured it was our one chance to,
um,
a break,
backward compatibility,
break the things that need breaking,
keep all the things that make parole
parole,
keep it a joy to use.
And with this make it a language that
will be able to be useful and enjoyable
for decades.
Um,
and so,
uh,
I,
I'd recommend Pearl,
but I'm known to be prejudiced in the
matter.